i'm a full-fledged dog dad and enjoying
every minute of it
i'm taylor hall here in boston i've
discovered a lot of great places since i
moved here and today i'm gonna hit some
great local businesses with a little
help from my wells fargo active cash
visa card
we are at polka dot bakery in the south
end this is where i go to get my dog his
favorite snacks he's been great since we
moved to boston he loves the city and
loves polka dot bakery so here we are
so what's your dog's name this is leo
he's a year and a half how'd you choose
a visa my fiance wanted a really
affectionate dog i didn't really want a
dog but
she
she kind of guilted me into it but i i
love him now like i couldn't imagine not
having him totally
these are his favorite though i don't
think he's ever had duck
all right thanks for everything
thank you guys take care great day thank
you
he wants one more treat
all right thank you thank you bye buddy
i'm gonna drop this guy at home next
stop is four now in the seaport i'm
excited to check it out hopefully we can
find something for my fiance rachel
hello
how you doing this is fun you know
getting to come to a store like this and
see what they have what she might like
these are cool though she'll love this
rachel and i got engaged then got you
know right to wedding planning and it's
going to be a great day on august 1st
this summer are these scarves i love
scarves so rachel might steal it
no i won't let her
i definitely like fashion a few years
ago i partnered with eyeglass brand
called bond look it's been a great
company to work with and a lot of fun
getting to design glasses that i really
like to wear all right found a few more
things here awesome oh my gosh she's
going to love this i know yeah thanks a
lot yeah no problem have a great day
thank you
seaport's one of my favorite parts of
the city i'm getting a bit hungry so
we're going to jet and go find a place
to eat
a lot of good stuff here clam chowder
obviously is a is a boston specialty pei
mussels canadian
there you go
all set to order over here yeah i'll do
the uh fish and chips please
we play tomorrow so i can i can afford
some extra calories hey taylor matt big
fan hey can i get a selfie yeah of
course awesome
thank you perfect
it's easy good picture man it's good
lighting
so we got perfect lighting in here for
the selfies
[Music]
awesome thank you you're welcome does
anyone want some no
i still
that was so fun shopping and hanging out
here in boston and i love that i earned
unlimited 2 cash awards on my purchases
with my wells fargo active cash card see
you next time